slow motion so now that the smoke from
the last election is clearing and donald
trump is gone the republican party has
to figure out what it is and what it
should be
is it going to be the gop of 2006
foreign wars plus corporate tax cuts the
party of john boehner and liz
that's what it's been for a long time or
will it become or is it already
something very different from that
something new and potentially much
broader than what it was
that's the question congressman jim
banks of indiana has thought a lot about
it
banks released a memo this week that
seems to answer that question
conclusively the republican party he
writes is no longer an arm of the
chamber of commerce in fact
it is already the party of the american
middle class and we know that
because they're its voters consider
these numbers
79 of mechanics who gave in the last
election
gave to the republican donald trump so
did 60 percent of small business owners
and 59 percent of custodians to the
republican party
when was the last time the republican
party won janitors
probably been 100 years at least the
democratic
party meanwhile has now solidified its
position
as the party of entrenched power 94
of college professors gave to joe biden
so much for diversity on campus
so did 73 of bankers and that's a
remarkable change
as recently as 2012 wall street donors
gave more than
three times as much to the republican as
they did to the democrat it was the
party of wall street
for generations but it isn't anymore
last year joe biden took in
four times as much from the finance
establishment as donald trump did
now congressman banks calls this a
paradigm reversal and he's absolutely
right about that it's likely permanent
huge groups of people have changed how
they vote
so how should the republican party
respond to these facts and they are
facts
well for starters how about stop sucking
up to the people who hate you
corporate america has gone mostly hard
left so stop doing their
bidding don't help the people who want
to hurt you
and then when you get a minute start
representing and defending
your own voters find the people who vote
for you and do something for them
the issues aren't complicated we know
what they're interested in control the
border
demand fair trade deals fight the power
of bid
big tech stand up for small business and
as you do all this
denounce wokeness as the moral atrocity
that it is wokeness banks rights was
cooked up by college professors then
boosted by corporations
of course it was and that's why normal
people hate it all normal people no
matter what they look like
consider this quote hispanic and
especially african-american voters
are even more put off by democratic
efforts to redefine sex than your
average voter
hispanic and african-american voters
oppose the equality act by ten and five
more points than the average voter does
and amazingly
42 percent of hispanic biden voters have
a negative opinion of the black lives
matter movement
and their opposition to the nuclear
family and their support for defunding
the
police compare that to just six percent
of white biden voters
get it not everyone is for this stuff
most people aren't and it doesn't break
along racial lines
at all the memo goes on like this it's
fascinating and you want to read it
banks ends on a hopeful note he ends
this way quote the democratic party
today is more
vulnerable than it's ever been in modern
history
the democrats agenda is now shaped
entirely by corporate interests and
radical elite cultural mores
but they still rely on many blue-collar
voters
that is not sustainable it can't
continue quote
democrats will keep alienating
working-class voters because that's what
their donors demand
and republicans should welcome those
voters with open arms by fully embracing
an agenda that is worthy of their
support end quote